nos preguntan cuál es el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 15 6 y 10 de 15 6 y 10 y
bueno un mínimo común múltiplo en
general se refiere a un mínimo común
múltiplo bueno sé que suena muy lógico
eso pero qué te parece si empezamos
mejor con 15 y vemos cuáles son sus
múltiplos así que me voy a tomar el 15
lo voy a poner aquí y vamos a ver los
múltiplos del 15 bueno 15 por un
esquince después tengo al 30 30 más 15
me va a dar 45 y si al 45 le sumamos 15
llegamos al 60 y otros 15 75 y después
le sumó 15 y voy a llegar al 90 y si le
sumó 15 llego al 105 y así me puedo
seguir y seguir y seguir con más
múltiplos de 15 pero vamos a ver si con
estos es más que suficiente ahora me voy
a fijar en el 6 cuáles son los múltiplos
del 6 bueno del 6 tengo el 6 mismo
después tengo el 12 después él
y 86 por tres es 18 después 6 por 4 es
24 después tengo el 30 después tengo el
36 16 42 48 después sigue el 54 y si a
esto le sumó 6 llegó al 60 y así puedo
seguir sumando y sumando y sumando 6 de
estos dos ahora si nosotros nos fijamos
solamente en estos dos y nos olvidamos
del 10 yo podría decir que el mínimo
múltiplo de estos dos del 15 y del 6
quién es bueno pues vamos a fijarnos en
cuáles son los múltiplos en común y yo
aquí tengo un múltiplo en común en 30 es
un múltiplo común en 15 bien 6 y además
date cuenta que es el mínimo también
está 60 60 es un común múltiplo entre
ellos dos pero el más pequeño de ambos
es 30 por lo tanto si solamente me
pidiera este ejercicio el mínimo común
múltiplo entre quince y seis pues yo
votaría de resultado 30 ahora no
olvidemos al 10
vamos a hablar también con el 10 cuáles
son los múltiplos de 10 bueno pues el 10
tiene como múltiplos 10 20 30 40 50 60 y
así sigue sigue y sigue pero si ahora me
doy cuenta de que también 30
un múltiplo común entre 15 y 6 y también
10 entonces ya podemos concluir que el
mínimo común múltiplo entre 15 6 y
también 10 es 30 porque es aquel que es
común de los 3 y además es el mínimo
común de los 3 date cuenta que también
tenemos el caso de 60 60 es un común
múltiplo de los tres pero no es el mismo
y lo que buscábamos en el mínimo común
múltiplo entonces ya tenemos la
respuesta el mínimo común múltiplo de 15
6 y 10 es 30 otra forma de hacer es
tomarnos la factorización de primos de
estos números y el mínimo común múltiplo
es el número que tiene todos los
elementos de la factorización en primos
de estos números y nada más
fíjate bien si nosotros agarramos el 15
y lo actualizamos en primos que vamos a
encontrar bueno que el 15 lo podemos ver
como 3 por 5 si yo factor hizo el 15 en
primos me sale 3 por 5
vamos a analizar qué es lo que pasa con
el 6 el 6 cuando yo es los factores son
primos esto es lo mismo que 3 por 2 el 6
actualizado en primos es 3 por 2 y si yo
me fijo en el 10 bueno al 10 cuando los
factores son primos obtengo que el 10 es
lo mismo que 2 por 5 que 2 por 5 y ya
que tengo a estos números factor estados
en primos entonces si yo me quiero fijar
en el mínimo común múltiplo déjame
cambiar de color el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 15 6 y 10 pues tenemos
que darnos cuenta de que al menos debe
de tener un 3 y al menos debe de tener
un 5 porque el que se reforma con un 3 y
un 5 por lo tanto el mínimo común
múltiplo debe tener un 3 por 5 porque el
15 se forma de esta manera ahora si
nosotros nos fijamos en el 6 el 6 para
que se forme debe de tener un 3 y debe
de tener un 2 pero ya tenemos un 3 aquí
y solamente debemos de tener un 3
para formar el 6 por lo tanto
necesitamos agregarle un 2 necesitamos
agregar en un 2 es más para que sea más
claro de estos 2 si yo multiplico 3 por
5 me da 15 entonces con estos dos
obtengo el 15 si yo tomo el 300 el 2 por
multiplicando estos 2 obtengo el 6 y si
ahora quiero formar el 10 pues date
cuenta que necesito un 2 y un 5 al menos
12 y al menos un 5 pero ya tengo aquí yo
un 2 y ya tengo aquí un 5 por lo tanto
ya puedo yo formar también el 10 con
este mínimo común múltiplo así que de
este de aquí y de este ataque de estos
dos ya puedo yo formar el 10 de estos 2
5 por 2 pueden reformar el 10 que es lo
que me faltaba entonces el mínimo común
múltiplo ya tiene un 2 ya tiene un 3 ya
tiene un 5 y estos son los números
necesarios para formar el 15 el 6 y el
10 y ahora sí podría decir que el mínimo
común múltiplo es la multiplicación de
estos tres que es lo mismo que
dos por tres es 6 por 5 es 30 llegué a
la misma respuesta y bueno yo te
recomiendo que utilices la factorización
en primos para encontrar el mínimo común
múltiplo porque si tú tienes números muy
complicados o complejos no creo que sean
nada sencillo tomar los 2 múltiplos de
ese número imagínate qué va a pasar si
tienes números en los cuales
necesitarías multiplicar demasiado para
encontrar sus múltiplos creo que esto no
sería demasiado factible y mejor podría
descomponer los en primos y así
encontrar el mínimo común múltiplo en
fin de cualquier manera estas dos formas
son válidas para encontrar el mínimo
común múltiplo